with more on all this we're joined by
Matthew Nussbaum White House reporter
for Politico Matt good morning good
morning for all the heat the president's
taking on the decision to withdraw from
the climate Accord agreement he has at
least succeeded in diverting attention
from the Russia probe as any for now I
think the Russian news whatever it goes
away it's only sort of a momentary
respite for this White House they
haven't been able to change the
narrative
I don't see why Paris would especially
with this explosive James Comey
testimony what's expected to be
explosive coming up next week now let's
talk a little bit about the political
calculations on withdrawing from Paris
we know that this probably plays well
with Trump's pace one of the
implications though for college-educated
moderates Republicans swing voters how
does that play in 2018 well I think it
elevates the issue I think we've seen
with governors and mayor's stepping up
it makes this an issue in 2018 midterms
and 2018 gubernatorial races it can be
hard to make the environment a
front-and-center issue but with so many
people in public opinion polls saying
stay in Paris with so many business
leaders with people like Barack Obama
and Mitt Romney saying stay in it it's
hard to see how this is a winning issue
beyond Trump's 30% of core voters who
are going to be with them no matter what
what do you make of the top
administration officials unable to
answer the question yesterday as we saw
about whether the President believes
climate change is a hoax
well it's bizarre we pushed on this in
the White House press corps on Tuesday
on Thursday and on Friday so over the
course of those days they knew we're
going to ask that question and they
weren't able to devise an answer so all
we have to go on are the president's
public statements on Twitter at campaign
rallies in which he says it's a hoax in
which he rejects the widely held
scientific consensus which doesn't seem
like a tenable long-term position what
what about the factionalism inside the
White House we know that Ivanka Trump
was not in favor of her father
withdrawing but even someone like
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson is now
out there on the international stage
sort of doubling down on US efforts to
combat emissions how is that tenable in
terms of White House management and
infrastructure if you have such
different views on this it sort of seems
to underscore the point that at the end
of the day Donald Trump is the Donald
Trump he was in his business career he
is the Donald Trump he was on the
campaign trail and he's going
go with his instincts which
ideologically seemed to align more with
folks like Steve banning folks like EPA
Administrator Scott Pruett so you can
have these so-called moderating
influences like Rex Tillerson like
Ivanka Trump but if they all have any
kind of influence we haven't seen it yet
be Gary Cohen
exactly you know you've got these in the
New York Democrats and some people
derisive ly refer to them that we hear
they have influence we hear they have
the president's ear but we haven't seen
any of that in the White House's actions
you mentioned the attention that's going
to be focused on former FBI director
James Comey 'he's testimony this week we
had we heard Sean Spicer say yesterday
that they were reviewing whether the
White House was reviewing whether to
invoke executive privilege this morning
their reports in the New York Times that
they're not going to try to do that what
do we expect here well I think first we
expected that they would try to invoke
this privilege it was unclear whether
legally they could and it would have
looked as though they were trying to
conceal something so that was a
lose-lose but I think this testimony is
going to it's certainly going to capture
the attention of Washington and probably
the whole country we know James Comey he
can make explosive declarations in front
of Congress he's a fourth quarter player
you know he knows how to go in there and
when the lights are on really delivered
these performances and I think
everyone's eagerly awaiting what he's
going to say and I think the White House
is worried about it
Matt every week under this presidency
there there are 17 different news
stories last weekend we were talking
about Jared Kushner his special advisor
son-in-law wanting to reportedly create
a back-channel to the Russians what do
we know about the investigation into
Jared Kushner ed present well there's
still a lot of open questions there's
the these meetings that took place with
Russian officials during the transition
there's these sort of unreported
contacts this effort with Flynn to
allegedly set up these back channels so
none of it looks good it looks as though
he's a person of interest in the
investigation as some reporting says and
all of it just makes it harder for him
and this White House to operate I mean
he's such a high-level aide it's hard to
see how he can continue to be in these
meetings every day while under this type
of scrutiny you know for the long term
tasked with everything from inverse
to Middle East peace he's a busy man
Matthew Nussbaum also a busy man thanks
for your time